[Music]
foreign
danielle thank you for coming to
20-minute leaders
thanks for having me of course of course
so where are you calling from right now
i live in oakland california our offices
are in san francisco but we're not going
in there right now so uh so yeah just
working from home right no yes i'm in
southern california and it's uh
it's just crazy times and i'm sure it's
you know
it's at 1517 fund uh you feel it quite
strongly
and i'd love to just jump right in we
know each other from about six years ago
and through a teal fellowship uh
weekend that i attended in downtown las
vegas which was
really transformative for me peter thiel
was also there
and you know i remember some of my best
friends until today
and dave fontenot and neda wang they're
they're they're
from that summit and i'd love to just
start tell me a little bit about
your background how you got to the to
start to help start something called the
teal fellowship
and then move on to 1517
yeah so um if someone had asked me 10
years ago if i would be in venture
capital i would have or if
someone had said you'll be in vc i would
have said what's vc
um i didn't know anything about the
industry so my
career has taken lots of twists and
turns
i worked in alternative education both
as a private tutor working with
homeschoolers i opened a charter school
in san diego that serves 400 students
we've been
wow around for about 13 years at this
point um
and 400 students now active
wow yep yep nope amazing uh
yeah it's been amazing to have something
that you know i was on the founding team
and um co-directed the school for the
first two years and
i'm i'm still on the board so i'm still
active in that sense but it's amazing to
have something that
i've handed off operationally um that
i'm not in the day-to-day of
anymore and i'm sure a lot of founders
have had that experience
uh with their companies as well where
eventually one thing that we see that's
interesting is eventually
you know you go from being a team with a
name that you call yourselves to a
company
and that transition is really
interesting but to answer your question
about the fellowship i
i had worked in alternative education
for quite a while i had moved up to the
bay area
i didn't know what i was going to do
exactly i had moved up here for an old
boyfriend
i lived in southern california at the
time and
i got a call one day from a woman who
worked at the teal foundation and her
exact words to me were
danielle they're launching this program
um
you know they've lost their minds they
need somebody who knows how to work with
young people someone who knows how to do
operations like
you are perfect for this um you should
get over here as soon as possible
i was like wow that's interesting i was
like who launches a program
without having all their like sort of
decks laid out
and everything's ready what is the teal
fellowship program
yeah absolutely so the teal fellowship
program which started in
uh 2010 so 10 years ago at this point
um was about this idea that
maybe university isn't the only path for
young people to
move forward with the cost of college
has been going up
year after year students are taking on a
lot more debt
and peter had this creative idea of well
what if you gave a young person
maybe instead of like asking them to
spend a hundred thousand on school
what if you gave them a hundred thousand
dollars to work on something
important for two years in science and
technology
and so it was this open question it was
also this question of
you know can we replicate finding
successful young people out there
um and you know silicon valley you know
has some history of doing this with
people like mark zuckerberg patrick
collison
of course like you know the greats like
microsoft and apple
um and so it was just like this
hypothesis and question of like can
we can we find more people like this and
so we put out a call to applications
in 2010 during that year we only had 400
people apply we picked 20 young people
we gave them a hundred thousand dollar
grant over two years
uh to work on a science or tech project
and there there were really only a
couple
um rules one rule was that you couldn't
be enrolled in university at the time
and you couldn't have a full-time job
somewhere else
so we really wanted people to learn by
doing launch new things
um and see what they could do
it was really amazing for 18 year olds
who were just out of high school
or was there a range so at the time we
said 19 and under
i think we could technically take
applicants who are 16
at the time um i remember we had some
people who were younger than that
in fact someone who is a current teal
fellow uh
shaheed khan he uh he was in our
inaugural
uh applicant batch and i have an old
screenshot of him
uh from like he sent in a youtube video
of himself
at i think he's about 15 maybe 14 years
old and he had sent it in we're like wow
we can't take this guy now but uh but
this is pretty cool that we have really
young people applying and then
i think it was something like uh maybe
seven ish years later
uh he became a teal fellow so
at the time it was 19 and under now the
program i believe is 22 and under
so i have to ask because you know you
you take 18 19 year olds and
and i'm you know i'm now 24 but i yeah
in the israeli military i
was a commander team of about eight to
10 18
19 year olds and you know i'm trying to
imagine giving some of them a hundred
thousand dollars
and saying go nuts yeah you had this
great proposal
now make it a reality yeah how do they
know how to do this this is a lot of
responsibility more money than most
will ever see in their bank account yeah
how how do you handle this
this responsibility as an 18 or 19 year
old
sure exactly great question um yeah i
think for a lot of people
it was really life-changing in that
moment because
it was one thing to write an application
and say hey i want to do x
um it was another to say hey you're
being granted this thing that you want
now let's do the hard work of moving it
forward
right ideas are a dime a dozen but
execution is really everything
you know with the grant we didn't give
out the 100k all at once that
that would have probably not been a
great idea um so
we've done stipends monthly we've done
stipends quarterly on that
um with the fellowship uh we would do
you know sort of like quarterly
high-level check-ins almost like a board
meeting
or a mentor meeting with people uh we
did regular check-ins outside of that
all the time with people to talk about
like hey how would you move this forward
what's your next step
one thing that we talked about a lot in
terms of selection is we were looking
for people who both had like a big
vision of something that
they wanted to do in the future we used
to ask this question on the application
you know what do you want to accomplish
within 10 years
but then there was another question we
asked what do you want to accomplish in
two
two years and then there was another
question was what do you want to
accomplish in the next two months
and the reason we asked about that
question was because by the time we were
going through the application cycle
we could see like what happened with
that it didn't mean like oh this
person's great if they got it done
what did they learn did they figure out
they had to pivot on something did they
figure out
that it's working out now they know the
next step so we needed people who both
could
see that big vision but also had boots
on the ground to be able to understand
what to do i
i mentor a lot of young people and a lot
of young people have the big 10 year
vision but then you ask them
hey what are you going to do on friday
to get there and they're like i have no
idea so scaffolding how you do something
is important and
we worked with people a lot to do that
and then in addition as the application
cycles went on
we learned about um you know it was
easier for people to scaffold things
when they had already gotten started on
it i used to liken it to
a marathon running i think the first
year of the program we were kind of
saying
hey marathons are really cool you you
are probably going to really like
running one we're going to pay you to
run one
the second year the messaging was a
little bit more like hey are you already
running a marathon yep we're here with
resources for you to run that marathon
uh and i think that was more clear um
you know but we've had people from the
first first class the second class
uh who have done very very very well um
people like retesh agual of oil rooms um
people like vitalik buderin i think he
was in the third class
uh with ethereum people like dylan field
he was in the second class with figma
dylan definitely fit that like already
running the race
because he was already already wanting
to work on figment already doing it a
little bit
yeah um but then we also had people from
the first group
who came in and they were kind of
feeling out what was gonna happen and so
then we had people like um
uh paul goo with upstart um you know he
was on the founding team
of that and it took him some months to
figure out like what am i gonna do how
am i gonna stop i'm sure
you know i have some i have two two
fantastic friends who
who went through the teal fellowship
program and ido gino
from rapid api and jihad kawas and you
know they
they oh yeah they couldn't talk enough
about how amazing it was both
you know obviously the grant is great
but the partnerships that they formed
through this program and the community
that they joined
is remarkable and and we i mean i could
talk about the teal fellowship for hours
but
yeah we only have 20 minutes and i need
to know your progression from there
sure now 1517 yeah what is it
and there's some interesting stick in it
that's
different from other fun yeah absolutely
so when michael and i were running the
teal foundation and the
the fellowship we saw some interesting
patterns and one of those patterns was
that when young people were out there
raising money it was hard to find
investors who would take them seriously
and
hard to find investors who would come in
early and
what we would notice is that we would
email investors and say hey
you know will you look at so-and-so's
pitch deck will you give them some
feedback now i'm an educator by
background
and so like giving feedback and and
offering an iterative process i love
that i think it's great
but a lot of investors want to see
something in sort of
primo like it's the right time come to
talk to me at this point in your
progression
and i get that they can't talk to
everybody all the time but what we
noticed was that some of our
uh fellows were really having
extraordinary outcomes like the ones i
mentioned
before and we said why are we sending
this deal flow
on to other investors when we have all
this information and we could start our
own venture fund to work with young
people and not just the app the people
who are fellows
but even the applicant pool like you
mentioned the teal summit
um we hear from people all the time who
came to our old events who were not
fellows but were applicants who came
they met other young people like them a
lot of times we would hear the phrase
from people i don't get to meet other
young people like me people who are
businesses people who are inventors yeah
doing more than school
were really hard for them to find and so
we said you know we think we could
support more than 20 people a year
with a venture fund and really repackage
the fellowship as a 2.0
we took this idea to peter in 2015 we
said hey
we have loved working with you and with
the fellowship but we really want to
repackage this as a venture fund
we love your blessing to leave the
foundation um
he gave us his blessing and he came in
as an investor
into our first fund and now into our
second fund that wow
um yeah it was it was an amazing moment
i remember when he
committed i smiled so big i covered my
mouth like i didn't
i didn't know what to do i mean that's
just the biggest vote of confidence
possible you know having worked with him
and such a such a noteworthy guy who did
such incredible things
and and working with him in the teal
fellowship and then saying i'd love
just your blessing for me to go and do
this thing that i believe and then he
says you know what
it's not even that i want to be a part
of this and i believe for success
that's incredible yeah no it was an
amazing moment and
and we went out and we uh in our first
fund we raised money from
30 other investors who were individuals
and family offices who also had that
same belief
and so now we have been able to work
with alum fellows current fellows
people who are old applicants other
young people we meet
now we're meeting a lot of people
through zoom typically we go to campuses
a lot
and meet people on campus because one of
our things that you mentioned earlier
earlier is our grant program yes so one
thing that we saw
and you've sort of mentioned something
in the vein of validation
a number of times of that it's not that
giving a young person a thousand dollar
grant which we do
somewhat regularly is a lot of money for
them to work with but it's the
validation
of that someone out there believes in
them
hey you know what like we'd have a young
person come to our booth it would just
be a table at a hackathon
and say hey i really want to work on you
know this project i have and we say oh
like
you know what do you need to buy to do
that or like you know how do you stretch
a thousand bucks to get that to
to work and they tell us about it uh and
for us we'd also be sort of looking at
like hey does this person have some of
the traits we look for in people like
insatiable curiosity is one like
is this person really passionate and
interested
in all kinds of things and and we've
been able to get a pretty good read on
people after even just a few minutes of
talking with them and and we would say
we call it a fairy godmother moment
be like guess what give me your venmo
like we're going to send you a thousand
bucks right now
and uh yeah so it's just it's a lower
paypal payment
yeah we make it really simple there's no
paperwork okay we don't own anything
that's that's crazy i mean i should have
gone to these hackathons
but well and and we take we take these
pictures these grant pitches over zoom
and things like that now here's the
really interesting part
so you think this is interesting that we
do this fairy godmother moment
what's interesting to me is that um
people have turned around with those
grants and built some really amazing
things and 20
of our fund one portfolio started as
grantees with us that's what i was going
to ask
20 of your portfolio is from these 1 000
investments
yeah unbelievable yeah it's really it's
been really nice we even had
um we had a young woman who actually
came to our teal summits who got a grant
from us who um
who raised so much money after she
got our grant that we couldn't even
participate it just didn't make economic
sense for us but we were like hey you're
off to the races
uh she's marie schnegens she's in uh
she's a french entrepreneur
um her app that she was building at the
time was called never eat alone it was
for
it was for people who work in large
enterprise to meet with each other over
lunch it started as this
sort of small product um but she really
built it out into an hr tool i can't
remember exactly what they're called
right now off the top of my head i
didn't expect to be
talking about this wow um but it was
amazing it was like wow and and
you know we have to get started with
that i mean so i have to ask because
this is so
unconventional you have a booth and you
have this i don't know this nine
this 18 year old or 19 year old
sophomore
and coming to the booth and saying hey
i'm excited about you know i'm excited
about drones and i have this idea
that i'm working on and and then you say
okay great
welcome to the 1517 family here's a
thousand dollars
yep yeah yeah that and and what we are
and we we always tell people that the
thousand dollars is a learning
opportunity it's a learning opportunity
for them to figure things out and it's a
learning opportunity for us too
um because then we can get to kind of
learn on the side of like
hey like what's easy about this what's
hard about this
we get to see how a person executes so
when that person comes to us and says
hey i'm i'm so close to having
you know a uh like a pilot ready with
somebody i'm ready to raise more funding
we now have a lot of narrative data
points on how that person works and how
they execute so it's really
easy for us at that point to make a
decision about precede funding
of uh of hey would we work with this
team because at the precede it's all
about the team and it's all about that
relationship
it's not about a spreadsheet i can't i
can't say to a founder hey send me a
spreadsheet with your financials because
there aren't any
um but the grant is one way that we're
able to suss that out and the other is
just building relationships with people
over time we've had many teams where
maybe a grant wouldn't have helped them
but we'll say hey like
we'd like to work with you more right
now you know the ideal is when someone
comes to us and says i'm not raising
money yet but i will be in
four to six months yeah like how do i
prep for this and i'm like oh good
i'm glad we're talking now the worst
case scenario is when someone sits down
with me on wednesday and expects money
on friday
especially if i don't know them because
it's really hard to like
get up to speed on the team and
um do they have the attributes we're
looking for anybody can have three good
meetings with an investor
but the question is can you do what you
say over time can you execute you can
build
can you deal with crisis like i mean all
these things are important and that's
something that
um you can't just get in a meeting
i think that's so awesome because you
you're catching them early you're
forming this
this honest relationship that has no
strings attached i mean they don't have
to
come to you for pre-season they can go
no they don't they can do yeah there's
nothing yeah they don't have to come
work with us later
yeah i guess it's it's a it shows the
virtue of
your of your community of that 20
of your portfolio are coming from that
thousand dollar grant
and that's just remarkable and you have
so many more data points than the
average
vc has on the team on the execution on
their progress
which is just phenomenal so sometimes
we've gone to people and said
hey and we do this we do this both with
grantees and portfolio companies we have
some portfolio companies right now where
we can see that a cash infusion would be
helpful to them
and we can say hey you know i know
you're thinking about around in four
months but how would another 150k help
you right now
and they're like oh that's great i was
just on the phone this morning with the
founder about that actually this is a
funny
moment the founder said like hey like
what if in the
convertible note we said we could take
up to 300k maybe you guys do 150.
and i said and we actually want you know
we wanted to do more cash than the 150
we wanted to do 250. he said will you
take 150 and i said
yeah i'll do 150 but listen like are you
saying that you want to market the other
150 to your other investors or what are
you saying he's like
well i don't know like i wonder if i
should put it out to them and i said
listen they're not doing their job
if they're not coming to you right now
saying hey i want to put in more cash
that's not my job to create an
opportunity for them my job is to create
an opportunity between me and you
yeah and i want other people to come in
and work
on this but i told that founder i said
we'll do the 150
but if you take more money on that note
i want first dibs
and uh and he's like okay fair that
totally makes sense
uh danielle this is we do that with our
grantees too where we'll say like hey
you know what it looks like
it looks like you're kind of ready for
like um
you know a larger cash infusion like
let's talk about what this could look
like and you know
and first off do you really want to do
this this is like
a five to ten year commitment it's a lot
of pain and suffering to start a startup
um and you know you have to be um
you have to be really into what you're
doing because there is no
glory especially the first couple of
years it's just
it's just a lot of work no no i couldn't
agree
more and i already have somebody that
right after this call from stanford
and i'm gonna uh tell him to go and talk
to you because
i think this is just the perf i mean i
just love what you're doing this is so
incredible
yeah and i wish we could continue but
unfortunately we know we're hitting the
20 minutes
um i'll just say this to end which is
that if anybody listening wants to reach
out
i'm just danielle 1517fun.com you can
email me
um we work with students from all kinds
of institutions we work
with people who uh have dropped out we
worked with people from community
college we've worked with
people from four-year institutions i
don't care where you come from in fact
in our pitch meetings we don't even ask
where you're going to school
or any of that like i just want to know
who you are what you're passionate about
and what you're building
that is so so cool so danielle before we
log off i'm gonna put you on the spot
one more time i'd love to tell me three
words that you think best describe you
oh man
best describe me let's see or that you
would you would like somebody to
describe you
i'll just go with best describe yeah i
can be aspirational some other time
be like heroic no just kidding um
friendly um curious
and um
goofy i'll go i love it today i love it
danielle thank you so much for this call
thank you for for inviting me to the
teal summit
six seven years ago which is one of the
one of the highlights
of my sort of entrepreneurial path that
i'm taking with me and i
really look forward to to maintaining
this relationship and keeping in touch
yeah same thanks for inviting me great